now for our daily cancellation today
we're going to look at a story that
actually
makes me angry if you can believe it i
know it doesn't seem like me to be angry
about something
but i am for a change of pace we're
going to be canceling the cancel mob
that came for a guy named john folk
last name spelled f-o-c-k-e i'm gonna
pronounce it folk
because that's the safest way to go i'm
not actually sure if that's the real
pronunciation
now anyone inclined to believe the
absurd spin that as many left-leaning
media outlets have claimed cancel
culture
is nothing but a myth concocted by
bitter conservatives
should consider the story of the
unfortunate john folk
the uh the announcer for the charlotte
hornets has seen his life
torn to shreds in the last few days he's
indefinitely suspended from his job he's
been condemned and ridiculed all over
social media
major publications and and national
media personalities are accusing him of
bigotry and worse
all because his thumbs
landed on the wrong letter while
composing a tweet
this was during a a game between the
denver nuggets
and the utah jazz john actually i'm just
going to call him john we'll just go
with john say first of all
john sent out a tweet about the action
on the court and the tweet said
shot making in the jazz nuggets game is
awesome murray and mitchell going back
and forth what a game
that was the tweet only problem was the
typo on the word nuggets
which through two errant twitches of the
finger came out as
the n-word now john deleted the tweet
fervently apologized for it it was too
late
his job was gone within hours there was
near unanimous agreement on social media
that either he wrote the n-word on
purpose or his phone auto
corrected to that word because he types
it so often in text messages and emails
that it programmed itself
headlines in publications like usa today
trumpeted the news
you know a guy named john folk tweeted a
racial slur they said
espn personality mark jones suggested
that
his phone corrected itself to the n-word
because folk had quote written it a ton
of times and trained it that way
and lengthy a lengthy yahoo news
editorial implied that john had
intentionally written it saying that the
claim of a typo quote strains credulity
and that the tweet signals that quote he
might have a problem with black people
so the scalp has been claimed a life
left in smoldering ruins
and the vengeful mob once again dances
in celebration around the ashes
all because of a typo speaking of
straining credulity
it is the absolute height of absurdity
to claim
that this man would intentionally tweet
the n-word
in some sort of maniacal act of
professional suicide
the typo explanation especially
considering that the r and t
and u and i keys are right next to each
other on your phone's keypad
is significantly more plausible than the
self-immolation theory that you're
getting
from the media the idea that the phone
had programmed itself with a racial slur
as an autocorrect is similarly
ridiculous
as far as i'm aware smartphones will
will not autocorrect
to profanity unless you go into your
settings and specifically install those
words as options
i sincerely doubt that john an nba
announcer who live tweets nba games
would have done that
is it really so impossible to believe
that this wasn't nothing but an innocent
mistake
made by a man who was merely trying to
send an excited tweet about a basketball
game that he was watching
in the whole history of people typing
the word
nuggets into their smartphone is it
impossible to believe that eventually by
a roll of the
dice someone somewhere is going to make
that mistake
no it's not not for any honest or
rational person anyway
so why the performative outrage why the
gleeful attempt
to destroy the life of some obscure
regional
nba broadcaster nobody's ever heard of
well
because this is cancel culture it comes
in several different forms but here it
is at its most
pernicious and loathsome sure
sometimes the mob tries to cancel
high-profile people like jk rowling when
they voice a really objectionable
opinion like
biological sex exists or some other
blasphemy
but it's especially toxic when it comes
for the obscure and the powerless
and devours them for the sheer pleasure
of the exercise
cancel culture is by definition
petty cruel vindictive and arbitrary
it is also entirely false in its motives
and its claims
the cancel culture mob is never
genuinely angry
never seeking real justice of course i
call it arbitrary but it's only
arbitrary in the sense that the penalty
bears no relation to the alleged
infraction
the victims selected are not arbitrary
john as a random white guy who committed
an accidental racial flub is the perfect
target
we know of course that if that if he was
non-white and had actually
intentionally tweeted slurs about white
people and admitted that it was
intentional
there would be no mob coming for him at
all and he would still have his job
so the victim selection here is not
completely arbitrary but it is again
petty cruel vindictive and also
hypocritical of course
it's funny that the people who called
for this dude to be fired are largely
the same ones
who'd insist that rioters and looters
and other
violent criminals should be given grace
and patience and their actions ought to
be understood in context
burn a house down loot a store assault a
random pedestrian break into someone's
house like we just heard
that's deserving of our understanding in
that case we should consider the overall
context
of of the actions but accidentally hit
the wrong keys with your thumb
death penalty you're finished that's how
it goes
because it's all a game to these people
in fact i found it quite appropriate
that the first tweet i read
when i typed john folk's name into the
twitter search bar yesterday this was
the first tweet it said the john folk
story is hilarious
fire that man yes how hilarious
fire him wreck his life there's no
reason to do it he doesn't deserve it
but hey
it's kind of funny if you're a sociopath
and
you know what else is there to do on a
monday you might as well
so for that reason uh this particular
mob is yet again canceled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content